[Musica]
[Applauso]
male
[Musica]
gli ammalati
maniera casuale
a male mi voti già mia mamma mi dia tuo
casuale
[Musica]
all
ma sì
[Musica]
rai
no
[Musica]
sì
su
vaccini
[Musica]
ururi barba
da me ma region a
tonara casa
la spazza lui
che la sua sposa
[Musica]
[Applauso]
non lo sapevo che in italia si potesse
arrivare anche per mare anche se malato
eppure il salato
maggio è un po improvvisato e perché una
furba emergenza e sopravvivere insomma
mamma
[Musica]
sono nato del mio cielo
la bomba ad ogni passo una tomba ho
perso tutto nello sporco gioco della
bellezza nel capo di una danza eppure
insieme agli amici poi cavo canzoni
avevo grandi abito eravamo impegni city
[Musica]
male
dopo due mesi di piatti o di fatiche e
speranze di serie di mancanze siamo
approdati in libia una nuova a te
ma anche qui solo quello tonio volo di
strada una camionista e tutti con la
verità sarà un bambino è già proporre la
testa dura
di la tua
ora
nostro vostro
male
[Musica]
[Applauso]
un piccolo scollo e questi decisero di
andare dove ricerca della racing sta
volando ora in testa ora in coda come
una coda sola
alla ricerca di simboli della storia
possibile di un'utopia quella che dopo
un viaggio per mare per terra ci vede
tutti uccelli migranti alla ricerca
della risposta a un bisogno di senso e
la trova in un canto corale noi siamo il
conosci dalle moto una comunità perder
l'incontro con tutte le diversità siamo
coca i veneziani a quelle della costa
d'avorio signori siciliani condor libri
incorporate il nostro canzoni
un cinguettio romeno vi vogliamo
anticiclici e togliamo il tedesco e in
inglese
i miei tanti migranti della grotta
mediterranea oggi volgono lo sguardo ai
fratelli e alle sorelle della rotta
balcanica
qualcuno di loro con ci può andare di
all'ombra nei campi con della della
grecia qualcuno di loro fioranti
dell'orrore magari dopo un inverno in
bosnia col fango e la neve che bruciano
in piedi non tanto diversamente dal
deserto della vita
[Musica]
invitiamo dunque sta alzando il volo con
noi forse software e il tempo di un
concerto forse per le prossime date a
steam al coro voci del mondo davanti a
te che seguiranno il nostro tanto se lo
vorrete potrete portarci atto uno
strumento musicale
stiamo montato una carovana per andare
incontro a quelle persone ai campi dove
restano bloccate alle comunità locali
che attraversano per ritrovare insieme
all umanità dimenticata per scambiarci
le parole e le canzoni
uno strumento e per chi lo vorrà un
proprio messaggio un recapito per una
relazione di reciprocità e di conoscenza
vieni con noi non importa chi vola in
testa di chi vuole in coda formiamo
tutti una cosa sola
[Musica]
[Applauso]
gesù mi vado a milano
[Musica]
chi ascolta
[Applauso]
[Musica]
ap
perché
[Risate]
[Musica]
magari
come stai
[Musica]
[Applauso]